[Music]
hidden figures so hidden figures is the
true story behind the brains behind NASA
and NASA the space race was going it was
America versus Russia we got to win the
space race because the brains behind
this monumental feat are these black
women you really didn't hear about now
we have their story really interesting
story too I mean this is a time when
women really didn't work in that field
let alone black women wasn't the most
progressive time this one of the things
this movie deals with it's like all
right NASA needs you go you want to help
out great that's awesome Oh NASA is not
saying you're equals you know that's
great you want to help and I got to tip
my hat to taraji P Henson she's in that
show Empire hope I pronounce her first
name right I suck with names it's a
thing with me she's in that show Empire
this was a great role for her is one of
those things where I'm like she's one to
look out for gonna be in some film after
this she does a great job not only for
the fact I just love it when people are
that smart who NASA's like we have a
problem and we have to solve it and the
only way possible Matt and she's like
I'm the best one at NASA at math this
poor lady's getting overloaded she's
like all right took one step forward as
ten steps back because everyday the math
changes one of the main bummers of this
movie it being a true story is that it's
Lady was so gifted at math had she lived
at a later time she wouldn't have been
so held back and probably would have
done a lot more but that is it the
hypothetical that I'm doing because it's
like well somebody that lives in the
time they're in or they don't live at
all fella you just delay that Octavia
Spencer was great - what I love about
this collection of ladies is that
they're all like we recognize where the
times were going and the times they are
a-changin not for the better for us so
we need to adapt we need to be very
adaptable and they are and I loved
seeing that angle kevin costner was
great also he doesn't necessarily agree
with all the segregation and NASA he has
one great scene where he really shows
what he thinks about it I thought that
was awesome his Kevin Costner's really
found his daddy Kevin Costner dropped
off the face of the earth at a point and
now he's found his stride in the
supporting roles one thing that didn't
always gel with me it was the personal
lives in the romance element we need to
see the personal lives if you don't just
workaholics know you see is the working
element of their lives and their careers
and you're like what were they like you
know as people and that is a tough
balance in biopics that are based in the
career world it's like we need to show
their personal lives but how much do we
show before it starts bogging the movie
and all the romance elements in the
movie I felt bog the movie down because
I was more interested in what was
happening at work but again if you don't
see it be we're gonna be like what was
her personal life like and if you don't
have her meet a dude in a world where
it's based on a true story and I guess
in real life she met the dude like he do
usually now she never found anybody
we're lying I'm gonna say it was just a
very informative film and is a testament
for what film can do there are these
stories out there in the world that you
never heard about nor would you ever
actually hear about had someone not
written a script about it and then it
got greenlit and now it's a movie I
granted there are pockets of people at
NASA I'm sure know this story normal
folks like me from the Northwest I don't
know a way I would ever find out about
it it's from a movie like this I'm glad
a movie like this exists in the end I
will say hidden figures is an
interesting story it's a fascinating
story the fact that this happened it
really slipped under the radar okay now
most of my age group I'm glad this movie
was made so I can know this story it's
such an important chapter in the
entirety of what is the space race and
what became the Apollo missions that you
just never heard about I will say hidden
figures is definitely a good time no
alcohol required alright guys so hidden
figures have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]